he's throwing the first pitch today for
the crew adrian hauser 27 year old
righty from oklahoma former second round
pick
we got action right away merrifield not
wasting any time getting on the base
pass that's exactly what i penciled in
for wit
you know he does use the whole field
but early in counts he looks for the
ball in and that's what you have to do
on hauser first two batters reaching for
kc
and salvador perez salivating with this
opportunity pitch number 15 of the first
the 2-2
slifted into right center field that
finds the fairway in the gap mirrorfield
rounds third will trot home monastery
turning on the burners he'll score two
nothing royals it's too good of a hitter
to leave that pitch there
and with monday running we talked about
the pressure he puts on outfielders not
just infielders it took a while to
return its ball to the infield just too
long to get a man that fast
better sprint speeds in all the baseball
for monday
all down runner going now to second base
throw gets away
and salvador perez will touch home plate
three-nothing kansas city danny duffy
the quote-unquote old guy
in the royals rotation yeah well when
they go out to dinner he's the one who
has to pick up the
rolls over on the 1-1 pitch over to
short
and they turn two
they do
a couple strikeouts for danny duffy here
to start off the second getting taylor
there danny duffy struck out the side in
the second three k's it's three nothing
royals
modesty pulls the 2-1 pitch
into right field
lead off base hit
as he goes to second bases the ball was
slow to get back in from ryan braun and
right
you can't give a player like that extra
bases no give monday credit for keeping
his head up
all right salvador perez at a two-run
double in the first inning up again with
a runner and scoring position
perez
breaks the bat goes into left center
field monteci gonna turn home
four nothing kc
and salvador perez you cannot stop him
right now
[Applause]
even when he breaks his bat it's just
everything's falling for him this is a
good two-seamer but
perez just muscles it pretty much the
competition he's done the most damage
against the ellics this year against
left-handed pitcher so something's got
to give here maybe it happens with the
2-0 yelich gets into one left center
field going back is olivarez at the wall
it is gone
solo home run for christian yelich in
milwaukee
is on the board
[Applause]
telling you steven i've seen it all this
week
the 2019 version of yelich we're seeing
more of it
again better stride direction
he takes
ball four four two
all right jacob nottingham what do you
got
bases still jam
nottingham turns on one to left field
didn't you
grand slam the brewers have taken the
lead
[Applause]
well i said the high fastball was the
way to go but duffy figures i'll start
him with a breaking ball
get ahead breaking ball and instead
nottingham just doesn't concede that
pitch it's a great reaction
hit off the fastball react to spin
look at where things are now
oh
that ball's hit well into left center
field and that one
gets over the wall a three-run shot for
orlando arcia
9-4 milwaukee
he says you stopped talking about my
teammates like that we can hit the ball
just fine
first pitch breaking ball again we saw
nottingham do that for the grand slam
missed opportunity for kansas city but
still plenty of ball game left it's 9-4
milwaukee
oh what a snag at second base nikki
lopez that is beautiful baseball
[Applause]
welcome to the big league scott blewett
he gets on the mound throws one pitch
and this is what major league defense
looks like
two steps and a dive
11 rubies his last 10 games
big spot in the top of the eighth
chopped to the right side huda ober on
to first
and kneeble the crew
escape the bases loaded jam
he's a big pitch right here needs to
throw a strike
he does and perez gives it a ride to
right center field
at the wall leaping he'll watch it go
salvador perez
goes bridge off hater and it's nine to
five
steven the reason i said it was a big
pitch was because you don't want to
start running up the pitch count
of josh hader in a five run game
[Applause]
the 3-2 from hader to starling
strike three
three strikeouts in a row to punctuate
a 9-5
milwaukee win